you stay poor until you've learned all
the lessons that poverty has to teach
and the first lesson of getting out of
poverty is Just Two Words my fault
because even if it isn't a person's
fault that they're in whatever condition
they're in it doesn't serve them to give
anything else the power to dictate their
life you have to relinquish the frame of
the victim no matter how true it may be
whatever you point to as your oppressor
as the reason that you're in this
circumstance is the person or the thing
that you give your power to I remember
when I was younger I was really angry at
my parents was it Justified or was it
teenage angst who knows it doesn't
really matter the thing that got me out
of that was realizing that every time I
blame them for everything in my life I
was actually saying you are more
powerful than me and I am a victim to
you so as soon as I realized that all I
was just doing was giving power to the
people that I hated at the time was I
realized I had to accept that I was the
reason that I was in this circumstance
because I'm the only one I can control I
can't control them and so by doing that
I went from being the victim to the
victor of my situation and I was first
able to say my fault